hello everyone and welcome to some big
news from the Chess World Vali became
India's 84th grandmas and also a third
woman from India to achieve the title of
grandmas but um for those of you who
perhaps do not know uh prananda is her
brother and the two of them are the only
brother sister Grandmasters uh in the
world that have ever existed there are
cases of brother Grand Masters and
sister Grandmasters like you have the
fforest brothers or you have the the
pogar sisters or or many other cases uh
but never has there been a case of a
brother sister Grandmaster so big
congratulations to V shy and um yeah
she's been having an incredible run uh
for for the past five years I would say
she started by winning her Norms in the
extra open in um 2019 then last year uh
she won the uh the um Fisher open the
Fisher Memorial the eth Fisher Memorial
Tournament and now uh just a few months
ago uh We've covered some of her games
uh she did incredibly well in the cter
Masters 2023 if you have you haven't
seen them uh do check it out the first
link in the description below first link
will be actually to uh a library of my
videos where you can easily search uh
all of my videos there are over 3,000 of
them and you can search them via VIA
player via rating via year via
tournament via opening used uh there's
even a a click you can use was B for
played in the game so it's a really an
amazing uh website to do use it if
you're if you're ever in doubt of of any
videos that I've made uh but yeah uh she
uh she won her norms and but to win a
grandmas title you also have to have a
rating of 2500 so she had she I won the
three norms and what I mean by this is
that you have to uh play three separate
events and in each event you have to
have a certain rating performance so you
will face Grand Masters there you will
face International Masters and you will
have to have a a rating performance that
uh will allow you to to be granted a GM
norm and you need three of those and a
2500 rating to be granted the title of
grandmas now you don't have to wait for
the month to be over as soon as you
touch the 2500 rating you immediately
granted The Grandmaster title and this
is what happened for Vali in round two
of the elat open that is currently being
played in Spain her opponent was FID
Master Tam tari selas uh now let's check
out the game as she said in the in the
interview after the game she was quite
nervous as she knew if she wins this
game with the black pieces she does get
her Grandmaster title so let's check it
out Tam Tarik syus has the wine pieces
and he opened with Knight to F3 we have
Knight to F6 Pawn to G3 going for the
king Indian attack and now Pawn to B6 we
have Bishop to G2 Bishop to B7 uh sort
of the uh Queens side faneto variation
and now Pawn to D4 H we have Pawn to G6
and now Pawn to C4 so a little bit of
everything basically transposing into
the English uh Bishop to G7 and now both
of them castled so castles castles and
now Knight to C3 with have Knight to E4
V immediately grabs that square uh
before white gains control over it and
then you will not be able to play Knight
E4 but you can see that she's really
slow playing it she played B6 G6 she and
Ked both of her Bishops so he want she
wants to have a safe game uh but also of
course to maintain winning chances for
as long as possible as she is the higher
rated player here and of course she
knows a win will grant her a grandmas
title and now Queen to D3 usually moves
that are played here are just um
capturing the Knight on e4 or queen to
C2 is very popular here sometimes Bishop
to D2 but here uh we have Queen to D3
and now Knight captures B captures and
Knight to C6 we have Pawn to C5 uh
usually Knight to D2 was played here
opening up this diagonal but here we
have Pawn to C5 and it is now already as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh point is now that you are
preventing D6 as um you'll just capture
on D6 and you have a double C Pawn so
you really want to get rid of one of
your pawns and let's say black captures
this you can even play Queen B5 you go
after the bishop and the pawn you will
mess up Black's Pawn structure a little
bit and you will be very happy uh
getting rid of the doubled Pawn so
instead after C5 viali goes Knight to A5
and now we have Pawn to
E4 taru grabs the full Center here B
captures on C5 we have Queen to B5 again
going for the same idea you want to
capture on C5 with the queen not the
pawn uh C6 attacking and defending and
now just Queen captures and C5 we have
Pawn to D6 and now Queen back to A3 uh
Pawn to C5 now again opening up the
light Square bishop and not allowing
this to
be to remain a weak Pawn uh Rook to E1
and now C captures on D4 C captures and
Knight to C4 going after the queen here
but also just getting an excellent
Square for the Knight Queen to B4
attacking both the Knight and the bishop
and now Bishop to A6 defending both we
have Bishop to G5 uh putting pressure on
that E7 pawn and we have Rook to B8
going after the White Queen queen queen
to A4 and now Bishop to B5 now here you
could also just defend the bishop with
something like Rook to B6 or queen to B6
but Vali goes for active Play She
sacrifices the A7 pawn and uh will make
t really really work for his meal here
if he is to get his Queen out alive he
also doesn't have to capture on A7 he
could also just move the queen and then
the game continues but if you can
capture it you kind of have to capture
it it's a matter of principle and of
course capturing is the best move so
this is what tar plays uh and now uh we
have Queen to C8 sort of um uh
tightening the screws around the White
Queen and asking what do you play here
uh well there are a couple of moves you
could consider but uh you have to
prevent your queen from being trapped
and the cleanest way is to play A4 uh
the reason being that now after okay the
bishop moves let's say Bishop to C6 and
you play Rook eight to C1 you go after
the Knight now if you go Rook to B7 then
the queen no longer guards the A6 Square
you can play Queen to A6 and if you go
Rook to A8 then after Queen captures on
E7 Rook to E8 you will play Rook
captures on C4 you will give up the
queen but for a lot of material Bishop
captures and you will have a rook and
the Knight for a queen but also you have
the past a pawn you have the potential
of a pawn push in the center uh this is
roughly equal however after Queen to C8
uh Rook 8 to B1 was played by ttic uh
but now it's very much different
remember when I just said that um you
will have compensation for the queen and
you will also have the past a pawn
that's not really the case here here why
Charlotte plays Rook to B7 and now look
at this queen captures on B7 the queen
has no other squares you have to capture
on B7 Queen captures we have Queen
captures and pawn to A4 uh but now Pawn
to
H6 and what do you play here it's a very
very very tricky position again you can
play it but you have to be incredibly
precise and by that I mean you have to
play Bishop to C1 and now point is after
Queen to A7 you will play a captur on B5
and you will have this beautiful Pawn
here but in the game after H6 uh he
played Rook captures on B5 and now the a
pawn is gone we have Queen to A7 and now
you have to play something you're not
going to save your pawn and give up the
bishop so the bishop gets saved Bishop
to E3 and now Queen captures on A4 and
this is just a huge part of the
compensation that white should have is
just gone it's
uh the past Aon was
was to be incredibly strong so Rook to
B7 and now Knight captures on E3 she
further trades down F captures on E3
Pawn to E6 and now Rook e to B1 tar
doubles up on the B file but there is
not much to be done here Queen to C2 was
played going after the E4 Pawn so Knight
E1 defending the pawn with the bishop
and now Queen to D2 just targeting the
weaknesses in White's Camp so Rook to B3
sort of trying to create a a fortress
here maybe white can hold H but now
other forces join the action Rook A8 we
have Pawn to E5 and now the position is
completely winning for Vali but you have
to always be precise feel free to pause
the video and try to find the cleanest
way to end this and win Vali her
Grandmaster title while I give you a
couple of
[Music]
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the the quickest way to Victory and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to A2 and it looks like
a weird move yes because the bishop is
guarded by the Knight but you are um
going after the Knight not the bishop
here that's the idea so e captur on D6
was played but now Queen to F2 check
King to H1 and Rook to E2 and now
there's no defense you either pick up
the Knight here or the Knight moves and
you Checkmate the white king so here H3
was played but now just Rook captures on
E1 with check Rook captures Queen
captures with check King to H2 and now
Bishop to F6 guarding the queening
square Rook to B8 check King to G7 and
now Pawn to D7 hoping to get the d8
queen in but luckily the d8 square can
be defended with the queen so she played
Queen A5 guards the queening square and
that's just it there's nothing much you
can do here E4 Queen to C7 and he was in
this position on move 39 that t t svis
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so yeah hu huge
congratulations to valian India's 84th
Grandmaster and uh what what an
incredible performance but uh yeah in
case uh you know you you go out with
your friends and you want to impress
them with your grand knowledge tell them
that now the world has a brother and
sister Grandmaster combo which has never
happened before and uh well very very
incredible stuff uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it we'll see
what's next for vice Charlie now that
she has her Grandmaster title she has
the 2500 rating uh she will of course
try to improve get 2600 maybe 2700 as
she's still very young uh so uh I mean
sky the limit here and we'll we'll see
what happens and currently uh in in the
women's rating I believe she's number 11
in the world so she needs a few more
points to be ranked top 10 in the world
um of of women's chess but I don't think
she's all that much interested in
competing only in women's chess I think
she she wants to go all the way uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again big
congratulations I would like to thank
David gas and David Anthony Robert
quistal Diane Schwarz and keep up the
rapid for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day